et notre invité politique c'est donc
thierry mariani qui s'installe en direct
bonjour beaucoup d'être avec nous ce
matin député européen porte parole de
marine le pen on est enceinte pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale qui est représenté par olivier
biscaye il se trouve à montpellier
olivier et les directeurs de la
rédaction du midi libre jean olivier
bonjour l
on commence par l'ukraine série mariani
emmanuel macron s'est entretenu tenue
hier deux fois avec vladimir poutine
donc une fois tard cette nuit pendant
plus d'une heure il s'est également
entretenu avec le président ukrainien ce
que vous le créditer de contribuer en
tout cas d'essayer de contribuer à la
paix en europe le chef de l'état d'abord
je le critique contribuer à sa campagne
électorale
soyons sérieux deux minutes on est à
huit semaines bientôt d'une élection on
à la politique spectacle que emmanuel
macron adore ce que je pouvais revenir
un peu sur ces cinq ans demande à une
politique spectacle en matière
internationale vous souvenez la grande
rencontre en 2017 entre la
réconciliation orchestrée par monsieur
macron des rivaux des frères ennemis en
libye ça a duré quoi trois jours après
on a eu en 2010 9 au g7 l'arrivée du
ministre iranien ça a servi à rien on
l'a oublié le lendemain voilà je vais
pas vous parler du liban avec la
dénonciation des des oligarques que
libanais il fallait tout changer en
ukraine jusqu'à présent je vous rappelle
il ya aucun résultat concret là ça sert
à rien ce qui fait pour vous je dis
simplement du genre je dis simplement
que malheureusement ça se joue entre
etats-unis et russie
voilà et puis souvenez vous quand même
de la rencontre de monsieur macron avec
monsieur poutine il ya une semaine il a
été démentie par le porte parole du
kremlin une heure après son intervention
c'est à dire que monsieur macron
expliqué qu'il avait obtenu que
désormais monsieur poutine s'est engagé
à ce qu' aucune escalade et aucun
mouvement une heure après dimitri peskov
le porte-parole disait poutine a jamais
dit ça donc je crois que
faciliter le dialogue c'est bien mais en
jouant en deuxième division
malheureusement aujourd'hui les français
il faut savoir le reconnaître en joue en
deuxième division d'ailleurs pas que les
français l'europe c'est une crise qui se
gèrent entre les etats-unis et la russie
avant tout justement une question et y
est lié
oui thierry mariani alors vous
considérez qu'il est en campagne
électorale
mais malgré tout il est là où il faut il
est en train de rassembler l'europe
autour d'une position commune
mais rassemble et l'europe pour faire
quoi enfin attendez ça c'est des mots
pardonnez moi si je comprends bien
certains disent que la russie va envahir
l'ukraine je le dis tout de suite j'y
crois pas une seconde tous les matins
j'écoute la météo hélas 25e 28e 30e
annonce que la russie va envahir
l'ukraine dans la journée mais si je
comprends bien on nous annonce que la
russie va envahir lucrin l'ukraine et
qu'on va prendre des sanctions en
réalité l'europe dit quoi dit aux russes
si vous y allez on fera rien on prendra
des sanctions c'est tout c'est l'aveu
d'impuissance de l'europe parce qu'on
est en train de faire voilà je suis
désolé de le dire mais quand vous
discutez aussi avec des responsables
ukrainiens et 10 finalement ce qu'on a
compris c'est que si on était envahi je
le répète je le crois pas si on était
envahi l'europe ne fera rien mais quand
même la dîmière poutine joe biden ils
ont accepté de se rencontrer à
l'initiative d'emmanuel mâcon dans un
sommet proposé par emmanuel macron des
terriens l'algérien eu ce matin dans la
presse russe j'ai rien vu ce matin dans
la presse russe puis encore tuméfié par
c'est ça j'ai entendu j'ai entendu chez
vos confrères qui avaient le candy
sionnel pourrait se rendre compte très
et je répète jusqu'à présent macron nous
a habitués à des raids diplomatique qui
embouchent la réalité dans que des
résultats médiatique et c'est tout voilà
la diplomatie ça se fait pas en direct
ça se fait pas encore vos quand tous les
journalistes
la diplomatie ça se fait avec une vision
stratégique
ça se fait en discutant n'y a pas de
vision stratégique pour vous aujourd'hui
à il a jamais eu je veux dire si on
parle du bilan de politique étrangère de
d'emmanuel macron pardonnez-moi mais
du moyen orient au sahel en passant par
les pays de l'est ce bilan est nul il ya
beaucoup de cartes postales comme celle
là mais qu'on me dise un seul endroit où
il ya un succès diplomatique je suis
preneur ou dit emmanuel me forger votre
plaisir
mais que seriez vous à sa place et que
serait autre candidate que florissant
des candidates d'abord elle oeuvre elle
aurait depuis des années changer de
politique c'est à dire que demande
marine le pen elle est pas du tout pro
russes comme j'entends elle dit
simplement qu'ils allaient qu'elle veut
une position équilibrée marine le pen
elle est pro française c'est à dire que
quand vous êtes comme monsieur emmanuel
macron aligné depuis des années sur les
positions américaines quand vous arrivez
à moscou vous êtes quoi vous êtes un
allié des américains avant quand le
général de gaulle arrivé ou qu'un
jacques chirac à un moment arriver dans
un pays c'était la france point et donc
si on veut exister sur la scène
internationale il faut avoir une posture
j'allais dire indépendante ce qui a eu
la france est ce que frau fera marine le
pen je vous rappelle que du temps par
exemple je reprends l'exemple de jacques
chirac c'est pas si vieux la france
avait un rôle parce qu'on savait que
c'est pas la voix des états unis or
aujourd'hui tout ça c'est trop tard
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que ça se
règle je le répète entre etats-unis et
russie et que la france et l'allemagne
sont attachés d'ailleurs surtout la
france à ce qu'on appelle le format
normandie c'est à dire en réalité on
essaye de faire des sous discussions
après que les deux grands et discuter
mais on sait très bien je le répète que
c'est pas là où ça joue malheureusement
oui dit emmanuel d'un concept un
président en campagne est ce que vu la
situation internationale c'est quand
même pas mieux qu'ils ne se déclare pas
tout de suite et qui reporte un peu ça
ça son entrée en campagne officielle
chez mieux que les contribuables
français payent les ses frais de
campagne jusque jusqu'à la dernière
minute attendez on a usé ya une semaine
cet épisode extraordinaire il nous a
annoncé le programme des prochaines
années pour le nucléaire c'est bien le
même qui au début de son mandat avait
expliqué le contraire et puis en plus si
je comprends bien il est venu alstom
expliqué qu'en racheter une entreprise
plus cher que ce qu'il avait vendu et
quand les ouvriers avec un certaine
courage un panache ayant dit monsieur
vous êtes un peu pour quelque chose 1 en
2015 et j'étais qu'un collaborateur
qui se faisait il se fiche de la gueule
du monde donc oui c'est mieux pour ses
comptes de campagne aujourd'hui je dis à
tous les français soyez heureux vous
payez la campagne de monsieur pour vous
ici il doit se déclarer maintenant
malgré la situation internationale
compliquée at à la situation
internationale compliquée c'est un
prétexte je vais dire il doit se
déclarer enfin ils auraient dû mais bon
il fait traîner comme tous les
présidents soyons honnêtes mais là ça
devient un peu indécent ce qui est
surtout indécent c'est la manière dont
ils profitent des moyens de l'état voilà
mais ce qui est surtout elle descend
c'est cette annonce en permanence de
grands plans comme si
il était en place pour trois générations
je rappelle mon petit adam 47 jours des
élections présidentielles donc quand ils
nous annoncent en tant que présidence
qui va faire jusqu'en 2027 2028 c'est un
peu guignolesque et justement allez on
va parler de cette présidentielle des
ministres le maire de cannes mer les
républicains de cannes et président de
l'association des maires de france à
dire qu'ils allaient accordé son
parrainage à jean luc mélenchon pas par
soutien mais par esprit républicain ce
que vous saluer cette initiative de
david lisnard absolument c'est une bonne
initiative
d'ailleurs david lisnard est un
personnage intéressant à suivre mais
c'est une bonne initiative parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a un vrai blocage
on a il l'a reconnu d'ailleurs lui-même
on a les trois candidats c'est difficile
de faire le tri mais trois candidats qui
auront une place incontestable monsieur
mélenchon monsieur zemmour et madame le
pen qui aujourd'hui sont à la ramasse
pour avoir leur signature donc je salue
son geste
êtes-vous de votre côté on nous écoute
et en tant qu'organisation je vais vous
faire une confidence on a une
mobilisation générale
aujourd'hui tous les élus et cetera dudu
et rennes sont appelés à aller prendre
une liste de mer est alors passé les
coups de fil toute la journée alors on
en est qui nous manque des signatures on
en est qui le manque des signatures je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce qu'il ya
une sorte désormais de terrorisme
des maires dans les intercommunalités
terrorisme
bien sûr parce que moi j'ai vécu les
régionales j'ai été reçu par un certain
nombre de maires le soir comme si
j'étais un résistant fuyant je ne sais
quoi pourquoi parce que j'avais des
mères qui me disait on vous soutient on
fera voter pour vous d'ailleurs j'ai vu
souvent qu'ils avaient tenu la parole
quand je regardais
commune mais vous comprenez
notre intercommunalité par exemple notre
agglo elle est tenue par christian
estrosi
si jamais j'appelle à voter pour vous ça
va je vais le payer dans les subventions
j'ai pas le droit d'hypothéquer l'avenir
de ma commune etc alors j'étais
terrorisé il n'y avait pas de mai mais
en clair chaque maire aujourd'hui se dit
qu'il peut avoir des représailles dans
son intercommunalité s'il soutient un
candidat qui n'est pas de la couleur du
président de l'intercommunalité vous
savez comme moi on est sur public sénat
vous savez comme moi que désormais
l'essentiel des ressources des communes
proviennent des intercommunalités moi
j'ai été maire 18 ans dans les années 90
j'avais 90% des recettes qui dépendaient
de ma commune aujourd'hui c'est plus le
cas or je pense que c'est ça qui a
changé le plus de choses parce que
paradoxalement
marine le pen ne fait plus peur
aujourd'hui elle fait partie du paysage
n'a jamais été condamné contrairement à
son père elle respecte faisait pas peur
elle aurait passé non je pense que elle
fait peur électoralement mais pas
démocratiquement personnes ce sérieux
peut dire qu'elle n'est pas un élu comme
un comme une autre voilà aujourd'hui le
vrai problème j'écoutais votre invité
précédente oui il faut réfléchir
aujourd'hui sur la manière dont on
parraine les candidats voilà je suis
d'accord françois bayrou a évoqué une
banque des parrainages c'est plutôt une
bonne idée pour vous c'est comme
toujours avec françois bayroux c'est
souvent plutôt une bonne idée le
problème c'est que ça reste une bonne
idée voilà on éteint
à une dizaine de jours je crois de la
remise en fête du conte définitif s'il a
évoqué une banque du parrainage mais
j'ai envie de dire qu'ils nous donnent
vite le guichet quoi qui nous donne
l'adresse du guichet je rappelle que
françois bayrou avait eu une excellente
idée au avant les présidentielles
c'était la fameuse banque de la
démocratie
ça a été oubliée semble-t-il c'est pas
sa faute c'est la faute de monsieur mac
fan du président de la république mais
je considère que en tant que soutiennent
la majorité c'était une de ces idées
principales il aurait peut-être pu se
battre un peu plus voilà donc ça n'a pas
été fait mais donc je lance un appel à
monsieur berrou qui nous donne le numéro
de téléphone l'adresse du guichet pour
les signatures parce que si nous le
donne dans dix jours ça servira à rien
mais personne n'imagine que vous n'ayez
pas les signatures c'est un peu comme
tous les cinq ans beaucoup de candidats
d'eau marine le pen font monter la
pression non là franchement il n'y a pas
de pression qui monte parce que c'est la
réalité la nouveauté vous le savez comme
moi c'est que le conseil constitutionnel
et ça c'est un progrès dit régulièrement
comme il ya des pots de signature donc
avant je vous rappeler on avait cet
exercice un peu médiatique où le
candidat disais mon dieu je les ai pas
et puis l'arrivée le dernier jour avec
610 signature parce que je vous rappelle
que quand on en veut 500 il ya souvent
des gaffes dans les formulaires il vaut
mieux en déposer 550 est donc
aujourd'hui on sait où on en est je
crois que de mémoire on en est à 370
vous avez pop remis le tableau tout à
l'heure et donc il ya vraiment le feu à
la maison il n'y a pas de ya pas de
psychodrame
voilà et puis et puis soyons c'est aussi
un peu logique vous avez plusieurs
candidats qui sent sur le même créneau
politique même s'il ya de grosse nuance
que ce soit monsieur zemmour que ce soit
madame le pen ou même series aimant qui
vous prend une partie de vos parrainages
non oui nous en prend une partie mais
j'aurais pas d'y être enfin il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de maires moitié dans
le vaucluse g5 six maires qui mendient
je te paraît très bien h paraît très
bien ton candidat mais je veux avoir des
problèmes donc voilà il se trouvait
ailleurs alors en général ils nous
disent à la dernière minute citant
banques quand la donnera mais bon la
dernière minute à l'arrêt bourreau elle
arrive quelques est ce que vous ferez si
vous n'avez pas vos parrainages à ce que
vous contester la légitimité de cette
élection je crois que les français la
contesteront voilà parce que qu'est ce
que voulez qu'on fasse on va pas faire
un coup d'état on n'a pas fait on
respecte la démocratie il ya des frais
liés à des règles qui existent qui à mon
avis aujourd'hui sont plus adaptés à la
réalité que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
mais il est évident que ce serait
d'abord pour le candidat élu quel qu'il
soit un immense j'allais dire doute
parce que comment expliquer que dans un
pays comme la france des candidats qui
dépasse 10% dans les sondages je sais
que c'est que des sondages mais bon
quand vous avez en a quasiment deux
sondages par jour en ce moment qu'ils
disent la même chose monsieur mélenchon
comme monsieur zemmour comme madame le
pen doivent pouvoir se présenter
oui ça serait un scandale démocratique
si par exemple eric zemmour n'était pas
candidat oui je pense aujourd'hui voilà
j'espère qu'il sera troisième à
l'élection et pas secondes mais quand
même il est non vous vous étonnez que
les combes s'inverse et qui vous passent
devant il ya toujours une possibilité
moi je vais être un second temps je
pense que c'est la meilleure chance dans
ce cas là pour monsieur macro et de
gagner eric zemmour c'est l'assurance
vie l'assurance survie de de maquereaux
plus que marine le pen bien sûr vous
savez j'ai écouté ce que disait le
sénateur ravier
pour qui j'ai de l'estimé il ya quelques
jours quand il est passé chez zemmour il
a dit et d'ailleurs comme un autre qui
s'est rallié le même jour lorraine
saint-affrique il a dit ah mais moi j'ai
la nostalgie des rassemblements avec
jean marie le pen défaite bleu blanc
rouge de cette ambiance du temps de
jean-marie le pen oui c'est la nostalgie
de quoi c'est la nostalgie de caen le
front national faisait moins de 20% et
été condamné à perdre aujourd'hui dans
les sondages vous le voyez même si ce ne
sont que des sondages au deuxième tour
très souvent marine le pen et devant
valérie pécresse pour affronter emmanuel
macron et avant la campagne
oui mais on attend quand même que
monsieur macron comment sa campagne et
il ya un moment où quand on va commencer
en campagne il pourra pas jouer les
entremetteurs entre téléphoniques entre
les uns ou les autres il va devoir
rendre des comptes aux français son
bilan est catastrophique je vous
rappelle accessoirement 600 milliards de
dettes de plus autre rallié c'est
nicolas bay connaissez bien puisque vous
avez souligné au parlement européen il
vous avait prévenu de sa décision on
s'en doute et je veux dire il m'a pas
prévenue mais bon on s'en doutait tous
façon il était théoriquement porte
parole et on voyait très bien qu'il est
un peu en retrait de la campagne il doit
démissionner de la coprésidence du
regroupement parlement européen pour
vous à ces faits il a démissionné du
groupe heidi c'est-à-dire l'intergroupe
qui rassemble les députés la même on va
dire aux mouvances français italien et
c'est donc ça honnêtement il l'a fait il
est plus membre du groupe idi voilà les
choses sont claires et mais quand il dit
qu'il ya des reniements de la parle
d'eux est ce que vous entendez ça non je
pense que là ils se trompent je vois pas
quel reniement ya je veux dire il ya
simplement aujourd'hui une candidate qui
fait un programme
crédible voilà et donc c'est la grande
différence c'est que j'ai envie de dire
entre le père et la fille entre
jean-marie et que je n'ai jamais soutenu
et qui à mon avis n'était pas crédible
et je crée eric zemmour à un programme
qui est plus lyrique que concret quoi
moi je suis frappé de voir toutes les
émissions télé que fait marine le pen
c'est pas la même qu'à cinq ans
c'est quelqu'un qui a préparé cette
échéance qui est précise désormais sur
les chiffres qui connaît ses dossiers et
par moments on s'affronte à la réalité
prenez les retraites par exemple puisque
c'est le dossier le plus emblématique
elle n'a jamais changé d'avis elle a
toujours dit quand on rentre dans le
monde du travail à 14 15 ans ou à 16 ans
c'est pas la même chose qu'à 26 ou 27
sauf que accessoirement entre temps est
passé le coc vide la gestion du coc vide
qui fait que vous le savez c'est la cour
des comptes qui a encore remis son
rapport il ya quelques jours on a 600
milliards si ma mémoire est bonne de
dettes de plus donc forcément on peut
pas faire le même effort financier quand
on a 600 milliards de plus ou de moins
de dette donc qu'est ce qu'elle a dit
elle a dit l'objectif ça reste 40 ans de
cotisations mais le résultat est
l'application il faudra d'abord une
période transitoire
mais thierry mariani est ce qu'on lui
reproche pas finalement de s'être trop
habib sy c'est ce que disent beaucoup
des rallyes et eric zemmour elle est
moins dur ou air radical et beaucoup
d'électeurs apprécié le discours d'eric
zemmour parce que il dit la vérité ou en
tout cas il est plus dur - que les
marine le pen est-ce que c'est pas ça ne
répond blême la dédiabolisation
je veux dire si je veux me faire plaisir
j'écoute le discours d'eric zemmour si
je veux gagner je suis avec marine le
pen pourquoi parce qu'en politique le
problème c'est c'est le possible c'est
pas se faire plaisir il faut rassembler
50 % des français voilà il ya toutes les
opinions d'abord quand on veut
rassembler 50 % des français ça veut
dire qu'on provoque pas une partie des
français et que ça veut dire qu'on joue
eric zemmour c'est un provocateur pour
vous je pense qu'à des positions très
maladroite la pause le discours sur les
prénoms c'est extrêmement maladroit par
exemple voilà et est donc je pense que
marine le pen ne fait aucun abandon elle
adoucit peut-être son discours elle a
d'abord aussi beaucoup plus travaillé
eric zemmour a à mon avis un programme
qui est très superficiel il a il a le
talent de ces formules mais marine le
pen a pioché un peu comment concrètement
on peut appliquer certaines idées alors
c'est vrai que c'est moins l'illusion
lyrique que certains peuvent avoir
mais c'est beaucoup plus concret et
c'est surtout désormais une candidate
qui est prête à assumer les plus hautes
fonctions parce qu'elle s'y est préparé
il vous dit il faut rassembler mais eric
zemmour souhaite réunit les droites
est-ce que c'est pas votre vieux rêve à
vous aussi
oui mais vous savez comme tous les rêves
quand on se réveille ils sont évanouis
je pense qu'aujourd'hui droite et gauche
c'est fini mais est-ce que reconquête
c'est pas le rassemblement national que
vous auriez vous quand vous avez
rayonnant je pense je pense que droite
et gauche aujourd'hui c'est fini c'est à
dire que vous avez vraiment une partie
mondialistes ou qui acceptent les règles
en gros et qui disent sans le dire mais
on le voit très bien au parlement
européen
la france se doit se dissoudre
progressivement dans un grand ensemble
européenne qu'est pour jouer sur le
câble marché mondial vous retrouvez
aussi bien macron que pécresse je
rappelle accessoirement que la plupart
des députés du parti républicain vote la
même chose que les députés de macron au
parlement européen et puis vous avez un
clan patriotes dans lequel je mets
zemmour dans lequel je mets marine le
pen voilà tout
c'est même quand ça veut dire que le
soir du 1er tour vous pourriez encore
vous rassemblez parce que là ça paraît
compliqué la campagne quand même et moi
je mets plus emploi pas le conditionnel
moi le soir du premier tour j'espère que
les amis d'eric zemmour appelleront à
voter marine le pen et si d'aventuré en
marine le pen était pas là j'appellerai
à voter pour n'importe qui contre
emmanuel macron il n'y a pas photo vous
savez un deuxième mandat d' emmanuel
macron chacun doit réaliser que ce sera
un mandat sans fil et on a un président
qui au début a été un peu naturel c'est
à dire on a vu son mépris de classe
transparaître son sentiment de
supériorité
puis après c'est quand même aperçu gilet
jaune aidants ou d'autres mouvements
qu'il fallait qu'ils se calment un peu
qui respecte un peu plus les français là
on aura un président qui passez moi
l'expression pourra se lâcher il aura
plus d'élections en vue et donc quand on
voit par exemple je pèse mes mots là la
répression sécuritaire la manière dense
elle s'exerce il y avait qu'à voir les
blindés dans paris ces derniers jours et
tout mais j'imagine même pas qu'un jour
marine le pen puisse faire ça parce
qu'on nous explique ray quasiment que
c'est le fascisme à nos portes voilà
aujourd'hui on s'est habitué à ça on
s'est habitué à une régression des
libertés on n'a pas le temps d'en parler
mais je pense que le pass sanitaire est
une régression des libertés même si je
suis totalement pro vaccin je le dis
tout de suite mais le pass and i ter est
inutile et sous prétexte de la crise du
covin nos libertés reculent et donc je
crains deuxième mandat de macron à un
mot puisque selon le parisien hier le
premier meeting d'emmanuel mâcon pour
avoir lieu chez vous à marseille dans
notre région avec renaud muselier à ses
côtés qui serait fraîchement rallié
qu'en pensez vous alors c'est déjà il
est ça fait longtemps qu'il a rallié je
vous rappelle temps des fêtes où les
pense que physiquement non mais tout
dépend ce que vous appelez à la
fraîcheur quoi c'est comme le yaourt
pour moi il est ralliée depuis
février
2020 oui 2021 voilà je rappelle qu'un
acteur février 2021 il est allé chez
mathieu castex demande des camps marche
viennent soutenir sa liste et il a fait
un accord donc si le fraîchement rallié
c'est muselier trouver du plus frais
s'il vous plaît parce que là il ya
péremption
[Musique]
oui c'est sympa quoi je veux dire il
avait fait un meeting qui avait plutôt
réussi la dernière fois mais bon c'est
comme tous les meetings la touche tout
le monde se souvient marseille il avait
énuméré les nationalités le problème ça
vous a pas échappé qu'il ya quelques
semaines il était encore à marseille
pour dire que la ville était dans une
situation catastrophique
cinq ans après cinq ans après macron il
n'y a rien qui a changé
oui un petit mot peut-être sur valérie
pécresse parce que vous la connaissez
vient vous étiez à lui élevé
quel regard portez-vous sur sa campagne
on parle d'un pécresse bashing vous êtes
d'accord avec ça moi je pense que c'est
plus pécresse on a mis en clown
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi les
derniers mois où j'étais au république à
elle demandé à ce que je sois vidé par
monsieur wauquiez parce que je tenais un
discours trop dur et là j'ai regardé son
meeting j'ai dit non mais attendez là
c'est celle qui demandait que je sois
viré qui tient un discours que je
n'osais pas tenir il ya trois ans donc
pu sérieusement on voit qu'en réalité au
delà la forme qu'elle ait loupé
techniquement son meeting franchement ça
arrive à tout le monde c'est pas ça qui
m'intéresse
on peut tous est fatigué à jour du
meeting et ses jeux l'été est là et et
point final donc moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est qu'elle tient un discours auquel
ne croit pas elle n'est pas sincère
pensait pas sûr que non c'est en réalité
valérie pécresse elle aurait pu elle
sera peut-être d'ailleurs premier
ministre de mac rend un jour voilà et
donc sa reconversion désormais droite de
conviction
c'est vraiment le mauvais rôle qu'elle
n'aura qui méritera jamais un césar pour
y être contraints législatives thierry
mariani en question dans ces trucs l'air
pas mal à s'alléger étaient 25 40
députés j'en suis très fier parce que
j'ai été élu et réélu quatre fois dans
le vaucluse est jamais battu j'ai été
député aux français de l'étranger j'ai
été battu dans la vague macron
25 ans ça suffit on revient pas en
arrière merci beaucoup merci thierry
mariani da merci
[Musique]